sadly the answer is yes I'm not against
you know letting people go from a
company but only when they have proven
themselves to be uncoachable they may
have performance issue or behavioral
issues and we sit down and say Hey
listen I need to bring this to your
attention and we're going to coach you
to be better but if they think they're
perfect and they think there's no room
for improvement and they prove
themselves to be wholly uncoachable then
yes we should ask them to find Joy at
another company but the same goes for
leaders and I've seen this I've seen
leaders who reach a level of success
where they believe simply because of
their rank or fortune that that means
that they have nothing else to learn
and they start surrounding themselves
with people who only agree even to their
worst instincts and there's no creative
tension anymore they can sometimes be
Beyond Redemption because they just
can't listen and if anybody's ever been
in a relationship with somebody who
refuses to listen and think they're
right all the time and can Gaslight you
better than anybody else well imagine
that person running an organization and
treating other people the same way